* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge
und indianischer Gesang *
Alright.
Wenn ihr einen weissen Stein findet,
hebt ihn nicht auf
oder nehmt ihn mit nach Hause.
Darin könnte ein Geist wohnen,
der euch dann plagt.
Mein Name ist Arthur Honegger. Acht
Jahre waren die USA mein Zuhause.
Arthur Honegger in New York ...
Als Korrespondent kam ich
in dieser Zeit ganz schön herum:
47 von 50 Bundesstaaten
habe ich besucht.
Auch heute noch beschäftigt mich
dieses grosse, verrückte Land
praktisch nonstop
bei meiner Fernseharbeit.
In dieser Serie will ich nun
mein unbekanntes Amerika entdecken,
abseits der grossen Politik:
neue Staaten,
neue Menschen, neue Erfahrungen.
This is my paradise.
Das ist atemberaubend schön.
Die Badlands: "Schlechtes Land"
hat ein Häuptling es genannt,
als sein Volk hierher verschleppt
wurde, ins Reservat Pine Ridge.
Schlecht vielleicht -
aber auch spektakulär.
In ein paar Tagen
reite ich hier durch -
wenn ich das mit dem Reiten
überhaupt hinbekomme.
Ich will vom Stamm der Lakota lernen.
Nicht nur übers Reiten,
übers Leben generell.
Ein vergessenes Volk,
das seine eigene Kultur
jedoch nie vergessen hat.
Mensch, Tier, Natur:
alles  e i n  grosses Ganzes hier.
Die Weisheiten dahinter
will ich entdecken.
Hey, guys.
Bist du Dave?
- Ich bin Dave.
Wer ist dieser Kerl?
- Das ist Sergio.
Es wird unangenehm,
mit dir ein gutes Gespräch zu führen
mit diesem Ding vor deinem Kopf.
Er nimmt die Kamera
sogar mit ins Bett.
Er auf dem Pferd mit diesem Ding,
das wird lustig zum Zuschauen.
Mal abwarten, wer sich auf dem Pferd
am lächerlichsten macht.
Wir sind alle Anfänger.
Sie können es nicht erwarten,
euch auf dem Pferd zu sehen.
Willkommen in den USA, in South
Dakota und im Pine-Ridge-Reservat.
Pine Ridge
ist ein sehr "anderer" Ort.
Im Reservat
gibt es faszinierende Menschen.
Doch sie neigen dazu,
schüchtern zu sein.
Kulturell bedingt
werden sie nervös bei einer Kamera.
Einige misstrauen
Nicht-Ureinwohnern sehr.
Wir werden erklären, was wir machen,
von wo wir kommen
und was unser Ziel ist:
andere Menschen
und deren Kultur besser zu verstehen.
Meine Kinder sind
viel bessere Kinder aufgrund dessen,
was sie von den Menschen
im Reservat gelernt haben.
Kulturell, wegen der Armut,
wegen des Fehlens von Egoismus
und wegen der Grosszügigkeit.
Das ist eine Tatsache.
Ins Reservat
fährt man nicht einfach so rein:
Dave Ventimiglia wird uns helfen,
in diesem Mikrokosmos
zurechtzukommen -
Dave kennt sich hier aus,
sein Hilfswerk Tipi Raisers
führt u.a. Reitexpeditionen durch.
So sollen die Kulturen
einander näherkommen.
Und das hier ist unser zweiter Dave,
mein Regisseur.
Er, Kameramann Sergio und ich tauchen
nun ein in eine uns unbekannte Welt.
Wir sind in South Dakota,
eine Stunde von Rapid City entfernt,
im Reservat Pine Ridge.
Auf einer Fläche etwa
ein Viertel so gross wie die Schweiz
leben hier rund 30'000 Menschen
vom Stamm der Sioux.
Sie selber nennen sich Lakota.
Bevor wir das Reservat
genauer erkunden können,
steht jetzt aber erst mal die erste
Reitstunde meines Lebens an. Okay.
Die Pferde gehören Hank Bringing-
Them-Back und seinen Söhnen.
Also hier, eng halten.
Nur mit den Fussspitzen?
Ich habe grosse Schuhe.
Alles klar, Arthur?
- Ja, wird schon gehen.
Hang on, hang on! There you go.
Habe ich die Zügel zurückgezogen?
Es tut mir leid.
Trete sie! Du musst sie
auf beiden Seiten treten.
Wie fest?
- Du verwirrst sie.
Du ziehst an den Zügeln
und trittst sie gleichzeitig.
Es ist, als ob du die Bremse zur
selben Zeit drückst und loslässt.
Okay.
Du willst dich nicht bewegen,
nicht wahr?
Hey, Adriano, würdest du dich auf
ihren Rücken schwingen
und zeigen, wie man sie bewegt?
Sieht eigentlich easy aus:
Zum Start kurz treten,
Zügel rechts ziehen für rechts,
Zügel links ziehen für links. Noch
fehlt mir aber das Gefühl fürs Tier.
Und so einiges mehr.
Ich möchte wirklich
diese Reitstiefel anziehen.
Ich denke, dann habe ich mehr Platz.
Wir haben welche drinnen, du kannst
sie gerne holen. Sie sind brandneu.
Ich kann dir jedoch sagen:
Es liegt nicht an den Schuhen. - Ja?
Sieh mal an, da hat einer schon
ein bisschen Erfahrung gesammelt.
Er hat sich daheim
eben schon vorbereitet.
Damit er angeben kann.
Wird jeder mal abgeworfen?
- Ja, das passiert allen mal.
Ich reite jetzt seit 20 Jahren.
Und ich bin schon ziemlich oft
auf dem Boden gelandet.
Du hast mit fünf
angefangen zu reiten?
Wahrscheinlich noch früher.
Komm, ich helfe dir aus der Ecke.
- Danke.
Denk dran,
seine Tritte waren kurz und präzise.
Halte sie in Bewegung! Ja, genau.
Arthur, du machst jetzt etwas
anders, und darauf reagiert sie.
Okay.
Du bewegst dich gerne, nicht wahr?
Es ist schwierig, das Tempo
zu halten, aber es war in Ordnung.
Ich denke, es ist gut gelaufen.
Du hast es gut gemacht
fürs erste Mal.
Es macht Spass. Aber man muss
eine Verbindung zum Pferd herstellen.
Das ist schwierig,
wenn man es nicht gewohnt ist.
Ich bin sonst
nicht viel von Tieren umgeben.
Ich hatte mal eine Katze, als ich
jung war. Aber das wär's auch schon.
Wenn du die Verbindung zum Pferd
erst mal hast, klappt es.
Das sagt man so, ja.
- Sie sind wie Menschen.
* Dynamische, tragende Klänge *
Am nächsten Morgen erkunden wir
das Reservat so richtig:
Zentrum ist die Stadt Pine Ridge
mit etwa 3'000 Einwohnern.
Von ein paar kleineren Orten
abgesehen
leben die Menschen hier
sonst weit verstreut auf dem Land.
Mitten im Nirgendwo
finden wir denn auch den Trailer
von Everett und Geraldine.
Dave bringt ihnen heute Lebensmittel
und einen Rasenmäher vorbei,
und Everett soll uns bald
auf Bisonjagd begleiten.
How are you?
Hallo, wie geht's?
Ich heisse Arthur.
Seht ihr die ganzen Rasenmäher,
mit denen ich gearbeitet habe?
Wow, Sie haben alle davon benutzt?
- Ja, Sir.
Wie viele sind das?
Ich lebe auf 2,5 ha.
Da braucht man viele Rasenmäher.
Und gibt es Schlangen hier?
- Klapperschlangen.
Soll ich das reinbringen?
Ja. Meine Frau ist drinnen.
Sie heisst Geraldine.
Geraldine? In Ordnung.
Hallo, sind Sie Geraldine?
Ich bin Arthur.
I'm Dave. Nice to meet you.
Wir leben hier seit 2009.
Einmal kam ein Doktor
aus Massachusets hierher.
Er wollte uns helfen
und gab einer Frau Geld.
Er gab ihr 8'000 $,
um für uns in Rapid City einen
anständigen Wohnwagen zu kaufen.
Aber sie tat das nicht.
Sie und ihr Mann
behielten das Geld für sich
und brachten uns diesen
heruntergekommenen Wohnwagen.
Die Holzböden werden hohl und weich.
Einige sind eingebrochen, also
mussten wir Bretter darauflegen.
Die Decke hat einen Wasserschaden
und die Wände sind rissig.
Was passiert, wenn es regnet?
Es leckt. Im Gang,
im Schlafzimmer und in der Küche.
Es ist schwer, Hilfe
von der Stammesführung zu erhalten.
Sie beachten uns nicht.
Diese Hoffnung haben wir aufgegeben.
Tut mir leid, das zu hören.
Gestern haben sie uns
den Strom abgeschaltet.
Weil wir die Rechnung
nicht zahlen können.
Wir haben niemanden hier,
der uns hilft.
War das Leben immer so hart für euch?
- Ja.
Das tut mir leid.
Everett
versucht uns dabei zu helfen,
eine Erlaubnis
für die Bisonjagd zu bekommen.
Er und ich gehen jetzt los,
um das zu versuchen.
Danach kommen wir wieder zurück.
Entschuldigen Sie, was war das?
Das ist Salbei.
Wir erzählen hier die Wahrheit.
Deshalb haben wir
den Salbei angezündet.
Wir beten mit dem Salbeirauch,
um das Böse zu vertreiben.
Ich fühle sehr viel Freundlichkeit
hier, nichts Böses.
Unser Haus ist Ihr Haus.
Wir sind gleich zurück.
Ihr könnt gerne auch noch
ein Bild vom Badezimmer machen.
Das Paar lebt hier zusammen
mit Enkel Thunder.
Vater und Mutter interessieren sich
kaum für den Kleinen.
Es fehlt an allem: einem anständigen
Trailer, Geld für Strom oder Heizung.
Die drei bekommen
zwar Lebensmittelmarken,
doch die sind oft Mitte Monat
schon aufgebraucht.
Wer hier, weit weg vom Zentrum wohnt,
hat Pech:
Die Stammesführer, so hören wir,
sind v.a. um ihr eigenes Wohl
und das ihrer Nächsten besorgt.
Das ist Sitting Bull.
Ah ja, da oben.
Was bedeutet er Ihnen?
Warum haben Sie das Bild aufgehängt?
Er ist mit uns verwandt.
Wirklich? Ihr seid
mit Häuptling Sitting Bull verwandt?
Das ist ein grosses Erbe.
Ich hoffe, dass er euch Kraft
geben kann in dieser harten Zeit.
Die Lizenz für die Bisonjagd
haben wir bekommen -
unsere Stimmung
ist trotzdem gedrückt.
Ich habe ja schon viel Armut gesehen
in den USA,
aber das Reservat ist da wie
ein anderes Land: Jobs gibt's kaum,
das Haushaltseinkommen
ist halb so gross wie sonst im Land.
Kaum eine Familie, die nicht mit
Alkohol- oder Drogenproblemen kämpft.
Die Lebenserwartung liegt unter 67
Jahren - ein Tiefstwert in den USA.
Die Geschichte dieses Orts
spiegelt die Geschichte Amerikas:
Bei seiner Ankunft 1492 denkt
Kolumbus offenbar, er sei in Indien -
und nennt die Menschen
darum Indianer.
Als die USA 1776 gegründet werden,
sind schon über 2 Mio.
europäische Siedler im Land.
Im Namen der Zivilisation
wollen sie den Kontinent erobern -
es folgen Kriege,
Massaker und gebrochene Versprechen
gegenüber den Ureinwohnern:
Hunderte von Verträgen
werden zwar abgeschlossen,
doch nie eingehalten.
Zur Gewalt kommen Krankheiten, die
von den Weissen eingeschleppt werden:
Die Urvölker
sind diesen völlig ausgeliefert,
weil ihnen die Antikörper fehlen.
Millionen Menschen sterben:
Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts
leben nur noch ein paar Hundert-
tausend Ureinwohner in den USA.
Sie sind es, die in Reservate
wie Pine Ridge gesteckt werden.
Die Regeln
machen auch hier die Weissen:
Das Indianische
soll ausgemerzt werden,
die sog. Wilden werden gezwungen,
zu leben wie alle anderen.
Bis in die 1970er-Jahre
werden indigene Sprachen
und Religionen unterdrückt,
Kinder ihren Eltern weggenommen
und in Internate gezwungen,
junge Frauen gar zwangssterilisiert.
Die stolzen Völker von einst
sind nun ein Schatten ihrer selbst:
Zu Bittstellern verkommen,
Opfer der Geschichte,
bis heute verfolgt vom Trauma
aus 500 Jahren Niedergang.
Fahr ein Stück zurück!
Mach dir keine Sorgen!
Halte die Räder gerade!
Es war abgeschaltet.
Wir waren im Zweirad-Modus.
Wir können nicht reiten,
wir können nicht fahren -
was können wir überhaupt?
- Zumindest haben wir jetzt Allrad.
Heute steht der erste Ausritt
für uns an - da müssen wir beweisen,
dass wir bereit sind
für die Badlands.
Sergio, wenn ich du wäre,
würde ich damit nicht reiten.
Sogar diese Jungs, die erfahrene
Reiter sind, schütteln die Köpfe.
Ich schlage vor, dass du nicht
mit der Kamera reitest.
Ich fühle mich nicht so schlecht.
- Wir bewegen uns auch noch nicht.
Ich nehme einfach diese kleine.
Ja, hier ist gut.
Nein, nein. Auto!
Hierhin. Nicht zu tief da rein.
Nein, nicht jetzt.
Okay.
Yes! Whoa, whoa.
Du musst deinen Sitz verbessern.
Drück mehr nach hinten.
Du solltest reiten
wie auf einer Welle.
Okay.
Wenn du so hoppelst, tut das weh
und es ruiniert deinen Rücken.
Aber hinten geht's auch rauf
und runter. Ich hebe einfach ab.
Drücke mehr in die Steigbügel.
Dein Zentrum sollte
beim Reiten felsenfest sein.
Ein wichtiger Teil
ist auch durchatmen,
keine Panik aufkeimen lassen.
Versuche ganz bei dir zu bleiben.
Es gibt so viel zu beachten.
Man sollte nie
aus dem Sattel gehoben werden?
Schau dir die Reiter an.
Sie sind wie Surfer!
Sie gleiten buchstäblich dahin.
Das Schwierigste auf dem Pferd
ist dieser holpernde Schritt.
Wenn du es auf die nächste
Geschwindigkeitsstufe schaffst,
ist alles viel sanfter. Es ist herr-
lich. Falls du es dahin schaffst.
* Tragende Klänge *
Whoa.
Ich bin sogar ein bisschen
galoppiert. Das war verrückt.
Es ist viel besser als Traben.
- Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Und dann passiert's:
Mein Pferd Wokeshapi und ich,
wir finden unseren Rhythmus.
Jetzt können die Badlands kommen.
Whoa!
Good girl!
Das war der beste Ritt,
den ich je hatte.
Du machst einen Masterabschluss
im Reiten.
Du hast in zwei Tagen gelernt,
was normalerweise Jahre dauert.
Wirklich?
- Absolut.
Dein Pferd springt, bewegt sich im
Galopp, folgt nicht nur der Gruppe.
Du hast viel Vertrauen in uns.
Oder wir sind dir einfach egal.
Doch, mich kümmert es.
Ihr haltet euch wirklich gut.
Die Lakota sagen,
dass auch die Pferde nicht wollen,
dass ihre Reiter herunterfallen. Sie
versuchen, sich um dich zu kümmern.
Die Älteren sprechen manchmal davon,
wie sie mit Tieren sprechen konnten.
Das erste Mal, als ich das hörte,
dachte ich:
"Ist schon gut,
sprecht ihr ruhig mit dem Wild,
den Bisons und den Vögeln."
Jetzt denke ich,
das ist tatsächlich wahr.
Sie hatten diese Verbindung.
Ich und meine Ahnen
haben sie längst verloren.
Wir hatten sie mal,
aber bei irgendeiner
Urururgrossmutter ging das verloren.
Ich glaube, hier gibt es noch Leute,
die das können.
Es scheint fast, als hätte unsere
Zivilisation einen Umweg gemacht
und findet jetzt zurück zu dem,
was wirklich wichtig ist.
Ich hoffe, das stimmt.
Ich hoffe, wir finden zurück.
So.
* Wiehern *
Wir brauchen zehn Säcke Eis,
also 200 Pfund.
Reicht das für einen Bison?
- Das werden wir rausfinden.
Der Bisonbestand im Reservat wird
von Park Rangern kontrolliert -
sie sagen,
wann ein Tier geschossen werden darf.
Da scheinen sie ja alle zu sein.
Wir sind hier mit den Rangern
und mit Everett verabredet,
der den Bison erlegen will.
Wie ist dein Morgen?
- Gut, wie geht's dir?
Ich bin immer noch hier, Sir.
Fühlst du dich gut?
Ja, ich hatte eine gute Nacht.
Sind das Äpfel und Orangen?
Ja. Möchtest du eine?
- Ich nehme eine Orange.
Dass Everett überhaupt gekommen ist,
überrascht uns ein wenig:
Gestern ist nämlich das passiert,
was häufig vorkommt im Reservat.
Laut seiner Frau Geraldine
war Everett
die halbe Nacht lang unauffindbar,
unterwegs, um zu trinken -
schiesstauglich sei er deshalb
heute auf keinen Fall.
Dave kennt solche Situationen
und hat darum seinen Freund Waylon
gebeten, mitzukommen.
Ich bin bereit.
Hast du ein Gewehr?
Nein, deshalb habe ich meinen Bogen
mitgebracht.
Mit Pfeil und Bogen ein Tier töten,
das so viel wiegt wie ein Kleinwagen:
Die Ranger sind skeptisch.
Wie nahe müsst ihr ran?
Wir schauen,
ob wir in die Herde reinkommen.
Wenn das klappt, nehmen wir
den Bogen, sonst das Gewehr.
Wir machen es, wie ihr wollt.
Die Gegend hier
ist Teil eines Nationalparks,
die Bisons können sich frei bewegen.
Das sind schon riesige Tiere.
200'000 dieser Tiere
gibt es heute wieder in den USA -
vor 150 Jahren
waren es nur wenige Hundert.
Einst gab es mehr als
30 Mio. amerikanische Bisons.
Teils wurden sie dann jedoch
gezielt ausgerottet,
um den Ureinwohnern
die Lebensgrundlage zu nehmen.
Nun hoffen viele Lakota, dass Bisons
wieder Teil ihres Alltags werden,
Teil der Seele des Reservats.
Was macht ihr sonst noch mit einem
Bison, ausser das Fleisch zu essen?
Wir benutzen die Knochen, das Fell,
den Schädel. Einfach alles.
Das ganze Tier.
Aus den Hörnern kann man Geschirr
machen, beispielsweise Löffel.
Ist das der Grund, weshalb der Bison
so wichtig wurde für die Lakota?
Weil man alles verarbeiten kann?
- Ja. Das ganze Tier.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Waylon macht sich bereit. Er hat nur
e i n e n  Versuch mit seinem Bogen.
Danach wollen die Ranger vorwärts
machen und das Gewehr auspacken.
Kannst du sie noch sehen?
Ja. Noch kein Schuss.
Er sollte seine Jacke ausziehen.
Er muss bereit sein.
Er ist nicht überzeugt von sich.
Denken Sie, er ist Anfänger?
- Ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir früher
oder später zum Gewehr wechseln.
Das wusste ich schon zu Beginn.
Er hat ihn.
- Wirklich? Mit dem Bogen?
Dave!
Er hat ihn an der Seite erwischt.
Direkt hier.
An der Seite?
Ist das gut oder schlecht?
Hier, mitten ins Herz.
Waylon,
hast du nur einen Schuss gebraucht?
Ja.
Ah, das ist der Salbei.
Das ist das Herz?
Das ist das Herz.
Und hier hat der Pfeil getroffen.
Der ist also direkt durchgegangen.
- Ja, genau.
(Mädchen) Das ist der Pfeil,
der den Bison getötet hat?
Ja, der hat den Bison getötet.
Okay, now: Do it real fast!
I gotta get those shoulders
over the ... Pull hard!
Dieser eine Bison liefert
über 200 kg Fleisch für Waylon,
Everett und ihre Familien.
Das bedeutet uns viel.
Wie lange wird das
für Sie und Ihre Familie reichen?
Ein Leben lang.
Ein Schuss, ein Pfeil, ein Treffer -
unglaublich.
Das grenzt an ein Wunder,
da sind sich hier alle einig.
Es ist das erste Mal, dass ich
mit dem Bogen ein Tier erlegt habe.
Noch gar kein Tier?
- Kein Tier.
Dann sollte es wohl so sein, dass du
gleich mit dem ersten Schuss triffst.
So musste er nicht lange leiden.
Der Wind
hat eine grosse Rolle gespielt.
Eigentlich wäre der Pfeil
so weit vorbeigegangen.
So the wind guided it?
Ein Pfeil, vom Wind geleitet.
Wounded Knee.
Hier sind wir an dem Ort,
der mehr als jeder andere
für das Leid der Lakota steht.
Liola Onefeather
pflegt diese Gedenkstätte,
die viel kleiner ist als ich dachte.
Es ist erstaunlich.
Bedenkt man die Schwere dessen,
was hier vorgefallen ist,
würde man ein grösseres Denkmal
erwarten. Es ist so bescheiden.
Vielleicht will Amerika
nicht erzählen, was es getan hat.
Wenn man so viele Menschen töten
muss, um ihnen ihr Land zu nehmen,
und sagt, man werde auch den Rest
töten, wenn sie weiterkämpfen -
so war die Aussage -
dann bin ich mir sicher,
dass sie hier gar nichts hinstellen.
Höchstens etwas,
das sie selber kontrollieren.
Aber ihr wollt
eure eigene Geschichte erzählen.
Wir wollen das Recht,
es aus unserer Sicht zu erzählen.
Gemäss unserer
mündlichen Überlieferung.
Anstatt
einer militärischen Darstellung,
welche die blutigen Geschehnisse
auslässt.
Es geschah im Dezember 1890,
zwei Wochen nach dem Tod
von Häuptling Sitting Bull.
Soldaten der 7. Kavallerie
verüben bei Wounded Knee
eines der grausamsten Massaker
in der Geschichte der USA:
Im Tumult, der bei der Entwaffnung
von Gefangenen entsteht,
sterben zwischen 150 und 300 Lakota -
darunter Frauen und Kinder,
niedergemäht von Soldaten,
die in blinder Panik feuern.
Weil der Massenmord
zunächst als Schlacht gilt,
erhalten zwanzig Männer
gar Tapferkeitsmedaillen.
Bis heute
wurden diese nicht aberkannt,
obwohl sich der Kongress
offiziell entschuldigt hat.
Wounded Knee war das traurige letzte
Kapitel der Indianerkriege.
Es ist beeindruckend, nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Darüber liest man in den
Geschichtsbüchern nicht viel.
Nein, tut man nicht.
Haben Sie vorher schon davon gehört?
Als wir in der Schule waren,
war es noch in den Büchern.
Jetzt aber nicht mehr.
- Nicht? Warum?
In den meisten Schulen
wird Amerikanische Geschichte
nicht mehr gelehrt.
Wirklich?
- Nicht viel.
Mir scheint, das wäre etwas,
an das man sich erinnern sollte.
Absolut. Wir wollten,
dass unsere Enkel davon hören.
Sie tun das Richtige.
Rund 80 Jahre nach dem Massaker
stand dieser Ort erneut
im Mittelpunkt eines Konflikts:
Ähnlich wie die schwarze Bevölkerung
mit der Black-Power-Bewegung
fanden auch viele Ureinwohner
damals ein neues Selbstbewusstsein
im American Indian Movement.
1973 besetzten Aktivisten
die Siedlung Wounded Knee,
bei Zusammenstössen mit der Polizei
kamen zwei von ihnen ums Leben.
Der Stolz der Lakota
jedoch war zurück.
Heute leben
knapp 3 Mio. Ureinwohner in den USA -
bei Weitem nicht alle
in Reservaten wie Pine Ridge.
Doch sind es diese Gemeinschaften,
in denen trotz aller Armut
der Reichtum
der indianischen Kultur auflebt
und den Menschen Kraft gibt.
(Mann über Lautsprecher)
Nupa Junior, four times champion!
Back to the bag!
Oh!
He's okay, he's about ten feet
from his horse now.
They're bringing the horse back to
him. He puts his shoes on.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
(Mann über Lautsprecher)
Es ist der Tag des Sieges.
Vor 150 Jahren
besiegte unser Volk die US-Regierung
in der Schlacht am Greasy Grass,
auch bekannt unter dem Namen
Little Bighorn.
In einer legendären Schlacht
besiegten die Lakota,
angeführt von Sitting Bull
und Crazy Horse,
die US-Armee unter General Custer.
Der grösste Sieg der Ureinwohner
wird heute gefeiert -
natürlich mit Pferden und
mit den besten Reitern des Stammes.
Auch Nupa gehört dazu,
der Sohn von Liola,
die uns die Gedenkstätte gezeigt hat.
Renn! Schneller, schneller!
Er muss nun
seine eigenen Schuhe finden.
Go, go, go, go!
Wer hatte die Idee dazu?
Die Idee ist ziemlich alt.
Älter als ich.
Es gibt viele Wettkämpfe,
die wir nicht kennen.
Das Stiefelrennen ist nur zum Spass.
Das Fellziehen hingegen bedeutet,
jemandes Haut zu retten.
Wenn ein Krieger
in der Schlacht verwundet wird
und draussen
auf dem Feld liegen bleibt,
muss man ihn da rausholen.
Man zieht ihn auf einem Fell raus.
Und das machst du auch?
- Ja.
Nupa ist bereit, loszulegen.
Macht eure Kriegsponys bereit!
Hang on, Coby!
Bleib drauf, Coby! Bleib drauf!
Alright.
Jetzt lass los, lass los!
Er ist immer noch drauf.
Nupa tritt auch
in der härtesten Disziplin an:
eine Meile - ohne Sattel,
wie die alten Krieger.
Zweimal bereits
wurde er dabei Zweiter.
Ready?
One, two, three, go!
* Sphärische Klänge *
Hey, Nupa, du warst schnell!
- Ich hab's versucht.
Glückwunsch.
Zweiter Platz, das ist toll.
War das gut oder was?
Bist du zufrieden
mit dem zweiten Platz?
Ja.
Es war knapp.
- Ja, schon.
Wie wirst du das feiern heute?
Daheim mit meinen Freunden.
Es ist ein Familienfeiertag.
Ich will mich auch etwas erholen.
Enjoy, man! Thank you.
Wie lange dauert's bis dahin?
- 5 Min.
Okay.
Habt ihr jetzt eine Idee,
wie wir das filmen wollen,
wenn man eigentlich
nicht filmen darf?
Das musst du uns sagen.
Also da oben wäre dann die
Sweat Lodge hinter der Bretterwand.
Gleich hier. Genau. Das hier.
Das Feuer. Siehst du schon den Rauch?
Unsere Kamera müssen wir jeweils
nur dann abstellen,
wenn den Lakota etwas heilig ist -
z.B. das Inipi, die Schwitzhütte.
Sie dürfen wir nicht zeigen.
Teilnehmen aber
dürfen wir an der Zeremonie,
Nabi hat uns zu sich eingeladen.
Ich bin ein Ältester, ich bin 65.
Ich entdeckte diesen Weg mit 40.
Das Reservatsleben
war wirklich schlecht.
Ich habe alles durchgemacht
und war wirklich am Boden,
wie man so schön sagt.
Das hier hat mich dann gerettet.
Diese Gebete, diese Art zu leben.
Wenn sie sagen "Mitakuye Oyas'in"
heisst das: Wir sind alle verwandt.
Der Kreis schliesst sich.
Wenn du für diese Menschen
aufrichtig betest und ihnen hilfst,
dann wird dir der Mann da oben
für deine Hilfe etwas zurückgeben.
In jeder Schwitzhütte
wird für etwas Bestimmtes gebetet.
Zuerst betest du dafür,
danach für dich selbst.
Du gehst da rein und reinigst
deinen Körper und deinen Geist.
Sobald sich diese Tür wieder öffnet,
beginnst du ein ganz neues Leben.
Okay.
Die Schwitzhütte
ist eigentlich ein Schwitzzelt,
hier versteckt
hinter einer Bretterwand.
Was dort gesagt wird, bleibt auch
dort, sagt man uns. So soll es sein.
Hier sei nur verraten:
Es ist stockdunkel, wir hören
Gesängen zu und beten gemeinsam -
statt "Amen" sagen wir "Mitakuye
Oyas'in": Wir sind alle eins.
Puh.
Was fällt dir als erstes ein?
Die Wärme da drin ist nicht nur
äusserlich, sondern auch innerlich.
Das, was man selten hat heutzutage,
so einen Moment der Stille,
den man gleichzeitig
mit anderen teilen kann.
Man merkt einfach, dass es mehr gibt,
was die Menschen verbindet,
als was sie trennt.
Vielleicht redetet man
zu viel über das Trennende
und zu wenig über das Verbindende.
So was wie hier, wenn man
einen Moment teilt und Dinge teilt,
das ist gut.
* Sirene *
Und dann eine Sirene, die durchfährt.
Passt ja auch.
Dann ist er da:
der Tag des grossen Ausritts in
die einzigartige Natur der Badlands -
schroffe Schönheit,
die einem den Atem raubt.
Und da soll ich noch reiten können.
Davor holen wir aber noch Joella
und ihren Freund Hoaks ab.
Sie wird für uns kochen.
Hey, wie geht's? Ich bin Arthur.
- Ich bin Joella.
Schön, euch zu treffen.
Wie geht es euch?
Wir schmelzen hier fast.
Entschuldigung,
haben wir euch warten lassen?
Ja, schon ein bisschen.
Aber das ist in Ordnung.
Es ist mühsam, hierherzukommen.
Ihr habt einen Schweizer Hund. Das
ist ein Bernhardiner, nicht wahr?
Genau. Sein Name ist Marley.
- Marley. Oh, Marley!
Joella ist 19 Jahre alt, arbeitslos -
und dennoch voller Tatendrang:
Sie setzt sich in Daves Hilfswerk ein
für Jugendliche in Pine Ridge.
Ich gründete ein Anti-
Selbstmordprogramm, als ich 14 war.
Das hast du selbst gegründet?
Ja.
Es heisst "Lass niemanden zurück".
Im Reservat gab es vor einigen
Jahren eine Selbstmordepidemie.
Damals habe auch ich versucht,
mich umzubringen.
Ich bin eine der Glücklichen,
die überlebt
und ihr Leben geändert haben.
Du hast versucht, dich umzubringen?
Tut mir leid, das zu hören.
Ich glaube, jeder hat einen Grund,
auf dieser Erde zu sein.
Viele einheimische Jugendliche
denken, sie haben keinen Grund,
weil es hier nichts für uns gibt.
Das wollte ich dich sowieso fragen.
Was tun junge Menschen
hier im Reservat?
Hauptsächlich Basketball,
Football und Leichtathletik.
Sport ist eine Chance,
das Reservat zu verlassen.
Die erste Vergewaltigung mit zwölf,
drei Fehlgeburten, Alkohol, Drogen:
Joella sagt,
sie hätte ihr Leben schon gelebt.
Ihre Freunde nennen sie darum Oma.
Aufgewachsen ist sie
in einer Familie von Alkoholikern
in einem Dorf am Rand des Reservats.
Mompley ist bekannt als Meth-Stadt.
Eine Meth-Stadt?
Ja, weil so viele Crystal-Meth-
Dealer da sind und Leute,
die von Meth abhängig sind.
Es ist verrückt.
Es gibt Zwölfjährige, die mit ihren
Pfeifen in der Hosentasche,
einem Feuerzeug und einem kleinen
Säckchen Meth herumrennen.
Hast du auch Meth genommen?
- Ja, hab ich.
Wie alt warst du?
Ich war 14. Fast über ein Jahr
war ich schwer abhängig,
und zwar nur, weil ich
dünn sein wollte. Ich war mollig.
Ich wollte Sängerin werden.
Mein Vater sagte mir:
Niemand will ein fettes Mädchen
mit Pickeln und schrägen Zähnen
als Poster an der Wand.
Dann hat er offenbar noch nie
was von Aretha Franklin gehört.
Kannst du stehen?
- Nur ein bisschen.
Soll ich noch ein Loch rauf mit
den Steigbügeln oder passt es so?
Du musst stehen können.
Ich glaube, ich versuche es so.
Ich habe ein ganz gutes Gefühl.
Ich setze mich einfach drauf,
reite hierhin und dorthin
und sage meinem Pferd:
"Hey, Baby, der Chef ist zurück."
Ich glaube, darauf reagiert sie.
Aber die Badlands sind anders, oder?
Hast du den Abhang gesehen?
- Ja.
Das wird
deine erste Herausforderung.
Es geht
auf beiden Seiten steil runter.
Wenn du es
durch diese Stelle schaffst,
ist alles gut von da an.
Die Badlands wurden einst
vom Gletscher ausgehölt.
Sie erstrecken sich über
mehrere Tausend Quadratkilometer.
In den 40er-Jahren
beschlagnahmte die US-Armee
einen grossen Teil davon,
um hier Bomben zu testen.
Über 120 Familien
verloren dabei erneut ihr Land.
Hey, kommt bitte
alle einmal hier zusammen.
Joella hat angeboten,
für uns zu singen.
Ich bin ihr dafür sehr dankbar.
* Sie singt mit klarer Stimme
ein indianisches Lied *
Whoa.
* Schnauben *
Puh, den Abstieg haben wir geschafft,
haben unsere Pferde geschafft.
Aber Filmen war dabei unmöglich.
Ich bin fast runtergefallen.
Sergio hatte v.a. ...
Kaum war die Kamera draussen,
ging das Pferd den Hang hoch.
Wirklich gerade hoch.
Vielleicht merken die das.
Hmm? Camera-shy?
Ich versuche, beim Trab
immer diesen Rhythmus zu finden.
Ich glaube,
man muss ein bisschen surfen.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Gut, so richtig eins sind Wokshapi
und ich noch nicht - aber ich fühle:
Wir könnten es werden.
Mensch und Tier,
Natur und Zivilisation:
Hier draussen
verschwimmen diese Grenzen.
Es klappt nicht immer,
aber manchmal schon.
Dann denke ich,
dass ich richtig gut unterwegs bin.
Und dann wechselt es wieder.
Moment, eine Sekunde.
Hoppla. You wanna go there? Okay.
Oh, here.
Okay. And there.
Wie bist du eigentlich
in die Welt der Lakota gekommen?
Da gibt es viele Gründe: die Kultur,
die Menschen, die Geschichte.
Zum Teil geht es mir auch darum,
ein Unrecht wiedergutzumachen.
Du hast ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Irgendwie hasse ich das Wort Schuld.
Ich muss ja nicht
hier draussen sein.
Aber doch,
ich habe ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Ich glaube,
das haben wir alle irgendwie.
Auch ich
fühle mich deswegen schlecht.
Ich bin zwar kein Amerikaner,
aber jeder ...
Du bist Europäer.
Die Europäer kamen hierher.
Hat es dich verändert, hier zu sein?
Tiefgreifend.
Eine Sache, die mich verändert hat:
Wenn man z.B. über diese Bäche hier
redet, die Flüsse.
Für sie sind das Venen
von Mutter Erde.
Seit ich die Welt mit diesen Augen
betrachte, denke ich mir oft:
"Oh mein Gott, was machen wir?"
Ich verstehe jetzt wirklich.
Wir können das
nicht einfach verschmutzen.
Das sind Venen,
das ist ein Blutkreislauf.
Zuerst hört es sich etwas esoterisch
an, schon fast etwas kitschig.
Aber je länger man darüber nachdenkt
und auch die Wissenschaft
miteinbezieht, ergibt es Sinn.
Die Lakota wussten zwar nichts über
Kohlenstoffdioxid und Sauerstoff,
ich kann aber
neben diesem Baum leben,
weil ich einatme,
was der Baum ausatmet.
Das ist doch erstaunlich.
Wenn das nicht beweist,
dass alles verbunden ist ...
Das ist denn auch, was bleibt
nach dieser aufwühlenden Woche:
Die Lakota leben völlig anders
als wir:
in brutaler Armut
und in spirituellem Reichtum,
in Bescheidenheit und stiller Würde.
Doch verbindet uns viel:
Wir sind ein Teil der Erde. "Mitakuye
Oyas'in": Wir sind alle eins.
Es gibt etwas, das mich
schon die ganze Woche beschäftigt.
Du sagtest, deine Kinder wurden
besser wegen des Reservats?
Ein Teil davon ist, denke ich,
dass meine Kinder
nicht nur mit der Lakota-Kultur
in Kontakt gekommen sind,
sondern auch
mit einer indigenen Weisheit.
Sie wurden damit
nicht nur konfrontiert,
sondern regelrecht hineingesogen.
Diese Art von Weisheit hätte ich
ihnen niemals beibringen können.
Ich kannte das nicht. Ich habe
gleichzeitig mit ihnen gelernt.
Ein Teil davon ist auch,
die Armut zu sehen.
Sie stellen sich die gleichen Fragen
wie ich und weinen deswegen.
Und ihr Vater
kann ihnen keine Antworten geben.
Das ist einfach so.
Und ich glaube, das ist gut.